- Our first guest couldn't be
more true to the storytelling
and the thematic nature of New York,
because she hails from Queens.
She is a rapper, a Golden Globe winner,
and, you know, superstar
from like blockbuster hits
like "Crazy Rich Asians."
(audience cheers)
I know.
Isn't that the best movie ever?
I've seen that movie 50 times.
She's in the amazing movie "Farewell,"
for which she won a Golden globe.
And she's most recently
in the number one film
across the entire globe, "Shang-Chi."
So, I know.
(audience cheers)
Her star just continues to rise,
and you can catch her on
her show on Comedy Central,
which I love so much, "Nora from Queens."
Take a look.
- We are hot.
- I look more like Owen
Wilson than I do Cameron Diaz.
- Selfie.
- Who's gonna take it?
- Oh.
- Okay, we literally
don't have time for this.
We have 23 stops tonight.
Let's go.
- How many stops?
- [Woman] 23.
(Drew laughs)
(audience cheers)
- Please welcome Awkwafina!
(audience cheers loudly)
- Hey!
- Hello!
- Hi, Drew.
Yes!
- Oh my God, I love you.
- New York in the building.
- Right, I mean Queens.
You are a queen and you're from Queens.
That's fitting.
- Yeah, appreciate that.
- You know, another queen
from Queens is Lucy Liu,
and I wanted to ask you because Lucy
had meaning for you back in the day.
And I would just love to hear
from you like what that was,
because I love her and I love you
and so I'm like in the middle
just wanting to know how
that story came about.
- Lucy Liu and "Charlie's
Angels" was like the pinnacle
of like everything to me.
And to see Lucy in a role like
that was really momentous.
It changed the way that I
looked at myself in the world.
And I will say that I don't think that
I would be where I am truly
without seeing Lucy Liu doing
her thing back in the day.
It's good.
- When I watched "Nora from Queens,"
and your storytelling is so strong,
the way, you know, humor
to me has to have heart.
It's like, but I want humor to push.
How do you have the bravery
to push that humor so far?
'Cause you go there, you don't compromise.
You're such a bad ass.
- You know, I agree.
I think all humor needs to have
kind of heart at its baseline.
A lot of the things that
I talk about in my show
are a mixture of reality or
like what I would imagine,
you know, my family or
like what they would say.
So I try to stick to that.
- What's so amazing is in
that very same episode,
you will break my heart
and make me emotional.
You know, when you talk
about your grandma,
and you did grow up in
Queens with your grandma,
and will you tell us about
that time of your life?
- She was definitely not, you
know, your ordinary parent.
I think like, you know,
she really kind of noticed
the spunk in me and I
remember I would ask her,
like, I feel weird, grandma.
I feel like I don't fit in.
I feel like, you know, people
think certain things about me
and I just feel weird.
And she always told me
the weirdness in you
is inevitably what's
gonna make you different
and what's gonna make you special.
She always told me that.
You know, she was always a big fan,
but she was also, you know,
like we got into shenanigans
together as well.
You know, there was a carnival
that would come to town for instance
and she didn't wanna
pay the admissions fee.
So they gave out these bracelets
with like little designs
on them and she was like,
let's just buy a marker and white paper
and I'll just tape it to your arm,
and we'll make your admission bracelets.
So I don't gotta pay like
10 bucks to get you in.
(Awkwafina laughs)
- I love that story so much.
And isn't it true when you were like 16,
she also told you something?
- She'd be like, you're 10 years old
so that we can go to the buffet
and you can get a child discount.
And she literally would like
slap a backwards cap on me.
And it's like, what is this?
What is a backwards cap
just code for I'm a kid?
- Yes.
- But it worked.
- Okay, another total juxtaposition
was something I was hoping
that you could share with our audience,
because I just thought
it was such a hot tip
and we could all benefit from it.
It's a beauty tip that you
gave to Allure magazine
with your gorgeous cover that
was so unique and dynamic.
- Absolutely.
So if you ever need a makeup blotter,
or like a face blotter,
just go to any airport
and just take a toilet a seat cover,
because that's what that is.
Yes, girl.
Yes, you can put your head through it too.
That's a necklace.
- It's true.
- Yes, girl.
- You could, and then you could actually-
- And make it fashion.
- And then-
- There you go.
And it's a bib.
- You changed my life with this tip.
So I just wanna thank you
because I'm never looking at
these suckers the same way.
(audience applauds)
(upbeat bright music)